well Hillary Clinton's daughter Chelsea
Clinton nobody should care about Chelsea
Clinton she hasn't done anything
interesting other than be the the
daughter of the clintons but they put
her on things all the time we have to
pretend that she's worth listening to uh
she was on The View and here's noted
racist Sunny Hassan talking about how
the Republicans are going to steal the
election your mom secretary Hillary
Clinton uh recently warned that
right-wing extremists already have a
plan to literally steal the next
presidential election I agree with her
on that but when we press uh Senator Ted
Cruz who's here on the show recently I'm
sorry I didn't bring a prop yeah
okay well when we press him uh on the
mega Republicans election denial he did
whip out some sort of prop and he argued
that your mother did the same thing
after the 2016
elections I'm pretty sure that I
remembered that next day I was standing
behind her when she conceded yes and
that she said while she had campaigned
very hard against President Trump she
hoped that that he would be a president
for all Americans that of course is not
what ultimately happened and so you know
I think that Senator Cruz just might
have a slightly different memory
okay so she's so deeply disingenuous
right there it's incredible she says
already well this is what Hillary said
they already have a plan now where is
the plan how come Hillary didn't be like
hey I printed it out here's the plan
right now they're making fun of Ted Cruz
revving props because you may remember
on The View last week Ted Cruz bust out
paper and on the paper he had the
evidence of a gajillion times roughly
that Democrats challenge the election
Now Chelsea is right in one I'll give
the devil is due Chelsea is right that
the day after the election Hillary did
not concede that night if you remember
correctly there's a lot of people that
said she was extremely drunk that night
I don't know if it's true that's just
what I heard what he can do bammy from
YouTube
um but the next morning she did concede
except she then over the course of the
four years of the Trump presidency along
with the major media outlets and big
Tech they all worked to undermine Trump
at every level when she repeatedly said
he was an illegitimate president who
knows I think she said he what was the
line counter he knows he's not a
legitimate president she called him ill
legitimate on Twitter and then said he
knows he's not on video a legitimate
president I believe he knows he's an
illegitimate president he knows he knows
that there were a bunch of different
reasons why the election turned out the
way it did if you do concede
right if you do concede but then you
spend four years
um saying that the guy is not legit is
that truly a concession I get it we had
a transfer of power but you know what we
also had to transfer power when Trump
left right because we've got the elderly
men pretending to be President Joe Biden
right now so the issue is that they know
that their political narrative is
collapsing and and as that control falls
apart
they are going to freak out more and
more